hey everybody Doug Walker here going
over real quick the cons I'm going to
this year 2017 c2e2 in Chicago Illinois
April 21st to the 23rd booth 387 I'm not
gonna be advertising this one I'm just
gonna be at a booth but that means you
can talk to me as long as you want but
the line fills up real quick so
definitely get there early Hollywood
Boulevard theater in Woodridge Illinois
this is not only a meet-and-greet and
the QA but we are premiering our
clipless review of Suicide Squad there
this is the first time we've ever done
it it's an amazing theater you can get
drinks and food and it's all themed and
themed theaters it's so great as my
favorite theater I can't wait to see you
guys there
fanime Con in San Jose California may 26
2014 1 of my favorite cons ever so
excited to go back to it and that's
gonna be July 6th to the 9th con Bravo
and Hamilton Ontario that's July 28th to
the 30th haven't been to this con in a
while I'm real excited to come back and
it's the only one I'm doing in Canada
this year so my Canadian fans come out
and say hi cuz but I'll be the only
champs Colorado Springs contine Colorado
Springs Colorado August 25th to the 27th
this is my first time going there so
excited to go and finally returning to
rhode island con in providence rhode
island november 10th to the 12th guys
the turnout last year was crazy i didn't
know so many people in rhode island
would come together for that and i'm so
excited to see you again and see new
fans so definitely show up there that's
about it if any more cons pop up I'll
definitely let you know guys I'm so
excited to see you again and there's
anyone I haven't met I'd love to say hi
definitely looking forward and I will
just see you guys there take care
[Music]
you